[Music]  a lot of people talking about the nba  playoffs how exciting they've been and  they're terrific games but there's  something else that's getting a lot of  attention the clothes that some of the  nba stars have been wearing to their  post-game  press conferences everyone's talking  about it let's look it was just like  that in the first series against  charlotte you know they had a lot of  guys we got some good looks  to go at one  i think we're doing pretty good  we can always play better obviously a  tough loss  [Applause]  they made shots and we didn't questions  good  we came in we came aggressive uh we  played some tenacious defense uh  everyone's very happy how'd you guys  feel about the next game  [Applause]  how many of those were real  three  i was amazed the first three are real i  love the backpack yeah